hoy en nuestra sección de Saludos vamos
a hablar de un tema que es bastante
interesante más Romero bienvenida
cuéntenos Cuál es esta idea de
anticonceptivo para los hombres es una
potencial fármaco que podría abrir un
camino bien inexplorado se publicó el
estudio en hecho communication entonces
una investigación de well cornel
medicine de rock University y Memorial
Slow cathering Center Entonces es un
convenio de varias entidades
estadounidenses y su propuesta por ahora
importante decir probada sólo en
animales en ratones particularmente no
en humanos todavía es un tratamiento no
hormonal es un fármaco que se toma se
puede se podría pedir digamos bajo
demanda y que impide la función normal
de los espermatozoides de forma temporal
con efectos reversibles en 24 horas y
que como decíamos si funciona podría
resultar ser revolucionario Por qué pues
actualmente existen Sólo dos métodos
para los hombres o para las personas con
pene que son los preservativos y la
vasectomía no y son hay estudios que no
han logrado materializar otras
alternativas por ejemplo hay intentos de
hacer terapias hormonales que bloquearía
la producción de esperma pero son
tratamientos muy largos antes de lograr
que una persona sea infértil y que para
volverlo reversibles también requieren
mucho tiempo además hay muchos efectos
secundarios algo que también sucede con
la terapia hormonal anticonceptiva para
las mujeres y ahí sucede algo uno un
poco cínico no Y es que en esa balanza
costo beneficio como los hombres no son
Quienes se quedan embarazados
normalmente el costo de los efectos
secundarios suele ser mucho más alto en
estos tratamientos al Buscar estos
tratamientos entonces bueno Esto que
funciona que es una terapia no hormonal
por lo tanto con muchos menos efectos
secundarios podría ser como decíamos
bastante revolucionario bueno bastante
revolucionario pero como usted lo dice
todavía están en las fases iniciales de
investigación entonces Todavía no
sabemos que vaya a pasar pero supongamos
que funcione Cómo funcionaría este
fármaco pues lo que han hecho es diseñar
una molécula químicamente no que lo que
hace es inhibe una proteína es
importante para la movilidad de los
espermatozoides Entonces esta proteína
es clave como decíamos al tomar el
fármaco los espermatozoides no se pueden
mover y por lo tanto no pueden llegar a
fecundar a ninguno óvulo en el momento
del sexo en este gráfico vemos digamos
en las barras son el porcentaje de
movilidad vemos que hasta las 3 horas
están prácticamente inmóviles y se
recupera esa movilidad hasta más o menos
las 24 horas y la línea descendiente es
el fármaco que se toma no la
concentración en sangre del fármaco que
se toma vemos que ahí está correlación
entonces bueno en el estudio que se ha
hecho por ejemplo en los ratones en los
que no estaban tratados más o menos un
tercio de los aparamientos resultaron en
un embarazo mientras que los que sí
estaban tratados de 52 apareamientos no
hubo ningún embarazo por eso decimos que
son resultados prometedores bueno
Esperemos que así sea mar cambiemos de
tema porque la Organización Mundial de
la Salud de la salud decidió mantener la
alerta sanitaria por la viruela del mono
explíquenos por qué sí la alerta sigue
siendo eso esa emergencia internacional
de salud pública que también recordemos
es el mismo estatus que tiene el 19
ahora mismo escuchemos
el comité reconoció El Progreso logrado
en reducir la transmisión de viruela del
mundo a nivel global y el declive
sostenido de casos desde la última
reunión
sin embargo más de 30 países siguen
reportando casos y la posible
infradetección de casos en varias
regiones es preocupante
particularmente en países donde se ha
detectado transmisión del virus entre
animales y humanos
la viruela del mono ya casi se nos está
olvidando Entonces esto bueno sirve como
un llamado de atención para recordar que
todavía hace falta tomar medidas y
hablaba de esos países donde todavía hay
un salto del virus de animales a humanos
sobre todo países africanos que
recordemos a pesar de este estatus y de
esta emergencia todavía no han recibido
ni una sola vacuna ni un solo
tratamiento para combatir esta
enfermedad y también hay un llamado de
alerta por la gripe aviar sobre todo en
el continente americano sí Argentina y
Uruguay declararon estados de emergencia
se suman a decisiones que ya han tomado
países como por ejemplo Ecuador o Perú y
ya son pocos los que Siguen sin detectar
este virus de la gripe aviar sus
territorios Aquí vemos el mapa falta
Venezuela Por cierto que también la ha
detectado en su territorio Brasil por
suerte todavía no Porque además es uno
de los países que más exporta apoyo
Entonces sería ahí también un problema
sanitario importante se llegarán a
detectarlo este nivel de extensión en el
continente es muy inusual normalmente no
bajaba de México el virus de la gripe
aviar además ahora ha pasado infectar
aves salvajes y migratorias no solo de
corral y ha llegado también a los
mamíferos en Perú por ejemplo se ha
detectado contagios en mamíferos algo
que demuestra Pues que este virus se
está adaptando de formas distintas a las
que conocíamos hasta ahora de hecho los
expertos ya están usando una palabra
para esto que es panzotea Es decir una
pandemia de animales está lejos de ser
directamente preocupante para los
humanos es decir no estamos cerca de que
este virus salte a los humanos y vuelva
a provocar una situación parecida a la
del covid 19 pero definitivamente pues
requiere una vigilancia cercana requiere
medidas de contención y recordar al
final que todo lo que impacta a los
animales una naturaleza también suele
tener un impacto directo en la salud
humano y ya tenemos pan su odio Entonces
por la gripe abierta Sí ya tenemos
pensado tía gracias mar por esta
información Gracias María Clara